now with reaction the GOP US Senate
candidate from Michigan John James is
with us and Turning Point us a
communications director our friend
Candace Owens Candace wasn't with Kanye
in DC earlier today you actually
facilitated a phone call with me and
Kanye and it wasn't there's a photo we
actually FaceTime and what what I what I
really liked about it is all he wants
his answers all wants our solutions all
he wants is opportunities and that's
what impressive I agree with prison
reform I agree with more jobs I want
more made in America I want a better
economy and I want safe neighborhoods
what is there to disagree with here the
fact that he likes our president the
fact that he's bringing forward an
optimistic message let's be clear the
left has become the party of hate and
division Kanye is talking about love and
unity and support for our president who
is doing a tremendous job he's talking
about the real numbers that are written
okay a 400% increase in in black growth
in jobs and starting black businesses a
four hundred cent increase black
unemployment an all-time low President
Obama brought an all-time high for
welfare for black community we had
President Clinton before him a Democrat
president who brought an all-time high
for black incarceration what is the
problem here why isn't the black
community standing with you right now
did he say was a billionaire yes yes
actually Fox News reported that how is
the banner how awesome and he's talking
about jobs that are paying 50 60 70
thousand dollars a year you know what
there are people that would love those
jobs let's get them here John James I
had the opportunity to interview you on
my radio show and I honestly I can say
this I'm on radio 30 years you just took
my breath away because of your passion I
hope the people of Michigan are getting
to know you I know it's a tough state to
run for Senate I hope the people of
Michigan are hearing what I think is a
great message to make Michigan great
again well the people of state of
Michigan are very astute this is a state
that not only did Donald Trump win but
so did Bernie Sanders people in the
state of Michigan are sick and tired of
being sick and tired and when you look
at the fact that 98 percent of black
people vote in one party
the reason while we don't have a seat at
both tables I'm an independent thinker
who prioritizes God in country in that
order and I will always serve the people
of state of Michigan as well as I served
the the United States of America when I
deployed to Operation Iraqi Freedom John
I went through Detroit the last time I
was there and I saw one of America's
great cities and it was devastated it
was I mean they're selling homes for $1
knocking down entire neighborhoods to
consolidate because of all the jobs
manufacturing jobs have moved out now
jobs are moving in to areas like
Michigan Wisconsin and and Ohio and
Pennsylvania I think we can revitalize a
city like Detroit am i a dream no or my
rooted in reality
look you're exactly on track we we know
that we can revitalize Detroit but the
thing is until these Economic
Opportunity improvements come to the
people in the neighborhoods are
forgotten neighborhoods and our
forgotten farms the the areas that have
been neglected and failed by Democrat
policies decades in the past we've
marched from Selma to Detroit we've
rioted from Baltimore to watts and
nothing's changed in 50 years we need to
make sure that we don't just happen to
be safe Chicago I want light for the
president to partner with Kanye and come
up with answers for the people of
Chicago it is a shooting zone and it's
been happening for years and nobody's
fixing it well we need more solution we
need more leadership and less
partisanship yeah you can learn a little
bit more about my candidacy on John
James for Senate comm but I have the
experience leading on the battlefield
and the boardroom and bringing my
leadership experience to solve and make
our neighborhoods better bringing
everybody up and making our Canada Sabre
why are people that are African
Americans in conservative brutalized by
the left because they don't want us to
be free listen make no mistake the left
depends on the black vote they have to
earn more than 85% of the black vote to
sustain their party this is why they so
division this is why they need the
themes of racism to stay alive but guess
what Shawn the black community is waking
up and that's why Kayne West
terrifies them because he's not scared
and they same way that I'm not scared
and we are seeing more black
conservatives waking up and speaking out
against Democrat Party I have a little
Hannity crystal ball and what I see in
my future are amazing futures for both
of you with strong leadership and just
dynamic personalities I wish you both
Godspeed didn't your mission as you move
forward and I mean that thank you both